my research focuses on building
computational methods to address
problems in
in biomedical sciences we are
particularly interested in developing
new methods to study diseases with
particular interest actually in cancer
before people been looking at diseases
from the perspective okay here's a gene
something wrong happened to this gene
and you have a disease but complex
diseases does not work this way the
usual is something happened to this
pathway something happened to this
process and when something happened to
this process you have a disease it's not
so easy to identify the pathway when you
look gene by genes because it may be
that every individual perturbation when
you look from gene by gene's perspective
is very small and it's hard to capture
but when you understand that you are to
look at the pathway in group of genes
the signals gets amplified and you may
be able to identify processes
that you wouldn't see if you would look
at genes in isolation so we are trying
to look at the diseases from the
perspective of this regulated pathways
some of our residents study in cancer
research are related to understanding of
the relationship between mutations
patients may have and say drug response
assume that we identify a pathway we can
ask the question
does the patient has a mutation in this
pathway and this gives us some way of
predicting whether or not the individual
will respond to drug those questions are
indeed very much driven by personalized
medicine
i think the goal would be some of the
methods that i've developed will have a
really lasting effect and also that some
of the biological findings would be
important for human health
you